but I think I think I'd be a horrible  sucker really I think the key to sucking  commitment I'm gonna be like a lazy  mouth I'll just be like you know what  just about it I'll just be like just  [ __ ] my mouth  you know it's interesting to hear  everyone's different take on it you know  because I can't be grossed out the whole  time I can't be like  is it that bad and I'm all like yeah  it's kind of bad do you have a strong uh  gag reflex Bark's committed though  that's the difference he could be like  you know this is gross but I came to do  a job if it's on Bart's calendar it's  gonna get done he's like suck it Friday  night  but sort the recycling suck a floss good  night